[Música]
ay ay ay qué bueno
me voy a pellizcar de estar en una
charla ted porque las amo las escucho
las veo siempre y cuando la propuesta
bueno fue estar aquí pensé en algo que
es algo que me viene obsesionando desde
hace un tiempo que está relacionado con
mi género y está relacionado con la
violencia que están sufriendo muchísimas
mujeres y entonces dije de qué manera
puedo aportar algo desde donde quiero
ayudarlas quiero tener esta esta empatía
de género esta solidaridad de género y
pensé también porque conozco y veo las
historias que hay muchas ellas que no
pueden salir de ese círculo de violencia
porque no tienen independencia económica
y empecé a reflexionar muchísimo sobre
ello y dije bueno la charla la quiero
hacer justamente sobre este tema porque
para mí la independencia económica en
este caso voy a hablar de las mujeres
pero de los hombres también es sinónimo
absoluto de la libertad quien no tiene
independencia económica no tiene
libertad para decidir y a veces cuando
veo esas mujeres con sus hijitos que
están allí con tanta violencia pero que
no pueden porque que van a hacer a dónde
van cómo empiezan entonces dije bueno
vamos a hacer entonces lo que cada uno
sabe yo creo que es lo que debemos hacer
en la vida y quiero contarles un poco mi
historia de como yo empecé y aprendí a
trabajar porque a todos se aprende en la
vida
yo me fui de rionegro a la plata a
estudiar periodismo y allí me ofrecieron
hacer mi primer trabajo que tenía que
ver con ser promotora de una casa de
electrodomésticos
dije que sí lo hice y empecé a tomar
valor de lo que significaba el trabajo
la recompensa económica el dinero y a
partir de ahí ya no parece
después vendía autos y se absolutamente
de todo
y empecé a sentir como una sensación de
poder porque yo sentía que podía decidir
o sea mi padre por supuesto mandaba para
que nosotros con mi hermana viviéramos
pero poder hacerlo ya de una manera
independiente decirle muchas gracias ya
hiciste mucho por nosotros en la vida
pero a partir de ahora lo voy a hacer
por mí este me dio una sensación de
poder y una sensación de felicidad
absolutamente que me encantaría que
muchas mujeres la disfruten empecé sin
que nadie me enseñara cómo era el mundo
del trabajo por dónde comenzar y
entonces hice algunos resúmenes que
quiero compartir con ustedes hay mucha
gente muchas mujeres que dicen bueno yo
quiero empezar a trabajar pero por dónde
empiezo cómo se hace
yo siempre les aconsejo que escriban lo
que saben hacer o sea cuál es el don la
habilidad que tienen en la vida y lo que
les gusta y la posibilidad de unir esas
dos cosas en algo y empezar por ese lado
la búsqueda y empezar saliendo de casa
porque cuando estamos encerrados o
cuando estamos en un círculo muy pequeño
es muy difícil yo siempre fui
extremadamente sociables
yo soy pero totalmente mamá decía cuando
yo era chica que era callejera detesta
siempre en la calle porque siempre
estaba comunicando me siempre estaba
haciendo cosas siempre estaba conociendo
gente o cuando me perdía decía hay que
buscarla porque hay un grupo de gente
hablando y tt está en el medio
escuchando pues fue curioso a toda la
vida y esto también creo que sirve
porque uno empieza a relacionarse y
poder contarle a parte de tu círculo
pequeño a otra gente que vos querés
hacer algo y empiezan a aparecer las
oportunidades y por otro lado también a
veces pasa que el círculo
t para un poco te detiene vos vas a
salir a trabajar pero no sabes lo
difícil que es eso pero no pero qué vas
a hacer por donde si vos no sabés muchas
cosas entonces también aprendí una frase
que les quiero regalar con todo el amor
hoy que la pueden usar todo lo que
quieran porque es una frase que para mí
hasta el día de hoy me sirve de una
manera fenomenal cuando alguien me
quiere parar cuando yo cuento
entusiasmada algo y me frenan digo no
pero yo no te estoy pidiendo permiso te
estoy comunicando lo que ya decidí hacer
la repito para que se la tengan se las
regaló yo no te estoy pidiendo todo con
una sonrisa y amablemente no te estoy
pidiendo permiso te estoy comunicando lo
que ya decidí hacer
eso contesta también cuando te dicen
para qué vas a salir si no necesitas
nada para que quieres salir de casa si
tienes todo
ah y entonces es cuando uno comienza a
ver que el mundo también es muy amplio
las posibilidades son muy amplias y sé
que cuesta no es fácil no es todo mágico
que salís y ya aparece entonces hay que
empezar para mí el hecho de vincularse
es muy importante hay muchas
instituciones solidarias que uno puede
comenzar para salir y para para estar
conectado con mucha gente que vas
conociendo vas haciendo vas viviendo la
vida la vida yo siempre siento que la
vida está ahí para ser vivida no y por
otro lado para mí es un incentivo muy
bueno el hecho de poder salir
para mí es como el oxígeno si yo me
quedo mucho tiempo en mi casa me voy
aplastando esto tiene que ver con mi
temperamento no quiere decir que alguien
no pueda trabajar desde su casa y pueda
hacerlo muy bien y no tenga por qué
salir pero el solo hecho de que salgo me
visto me peino me maquillo estella salgo
a la vereda ya ya ya me comunico ya
saludo gente ya estoy en contacto
también posibilita que esa cosa que a
veces yo siento cuando me quedo en casa
que me voy como como aplacando no pero
bueno esa es una fórmula mía cada uno
buscará su camino y buscará la forma es
interesante saber también que cuando uno
comienza a trabajar va a trabajar en
grupo
y hay que entonces entender al grupo
tratar de no entrar en chismes por
ejemplo sabes que fulana sale con fulano
y que entonces nada no entran en chismes
tu objetivo es trabajar es hacer algo
para el bien común y cuando trabajas en
grupo también a veces hay mucha gente
sino también que por ahí no sirve para
un trabajo y le comunican eso y siente
que hay un complot organizado en el
mundo contra ella que se pusieron todos
de acuerdo y entonces en vez de hacer un
análisis de en qué fallé en que no fui
buena o bueno piensa que hay realmente
unas fuerzas ocultas que estaban
esperándola para echarla
puede ser que haya alguien también muy
loco que te lo cruces pero bueno también
siempre pensar en lo que uno aporta al
trabajo no
sentir que todo trabajo siempre cuando
empezamos empezamos con algo pequeño es
sumamente importante y lo que tenemos
que hacer como me pasa hoy en todo lo
que hago este todo para mí lo que hago
en este momento está charla para mí es
lo más importante del mundo no me
interesa más nada mientras lo estoy
haciendo y en el trabajo también si vos
estás pensando todo el tiempo que estás
para más no y lo decís aparte que
después se te graba eso no yo estoy acá
pero en realidad yo estoy para más en
cualquier momento me descubren y va a
saber para dónde llegó no hace bien el
trabajo que te toca ser ahora que te van
a descubrir cuando veas que a sentir que
haces bien tu trabajo y vas a ir
evolucionando por supuesto que sí desde
ya pero no esa sensación que no tiene
que tiene por supuesto que ver con una
sensación de que no sirvo que no valgo
y después
saber aprovechar las redes las redes son
maravillosas en las redes hay todo lo
que te gusta puedes investigar podés ver
lo que se hace en el mundo vos con una
computadora con un teléfono sos la
capital del mundo y si no sabes usarlas
empezar a buscar algún chico más joven o
alguien que sepa y le decís ven y
enséñame yo por ejemplo cada vez que
tenía ahora ya aprendí pero cuando
empezaron los teléfonos celulares que
viste era una complicación yo iba a la
oficina y le decía a un chico ven y por
favor pensar que soy tu mamá así que
tenemos paciencia y explícame todo lo
que tengo que hacer porque hacía mucho
lío y vas aprendiendo cuando te metes en
las redes no solamente hay lugares de
búsqueda de trabajo está todo
absolutamente vos decir bueno yo tengo
una cierta habilidad no sé soy
carpintero soy hago comidas ricas es te
puedo viste que ahora hay una profesión
fabulosa para las mujeres que es ordenar
las casas
hay una japonesa que me megamillonaria
porque nos enseña algo que las mujeres
hacemos desde que nacemos que es ordenar
un placar ordenar la cocina y todo bueno
entonces pensar en las cosas que uno
puede hacer como servicio porque si yo
no soy una profesional por donde empiezo
pensar o sea por eso es interesante
conectarte porque vas a empezando a ver
ideas por todos lados absolutamente otra
de las cosas que aprendí es a ser
extremadamente agradecida yo soy
agradecida por todo porque realmente
bueno el hecho de estar viva ya es un
privilegio absoluto y el hecho de poder
hacer lo que me gusta
es algo extraordinario realmente lo
agradezco pero lo agradezco de corazón
como agradezco también este quien me da
trabajo yo lo cuido a mi trabajo lo
respeto lo honró hay que honrar porque
cada uno de nosotros tiene un don o
varios dones en la vida y si uno lo son
rezos dones después puede realmente
tener una vida de creatividad por
ejemplo que es algo maravilloso dormirte
a la noche con la sensación de que has
podido hacer algo que soñaste que
pensaste es un sueño que realmente es de
una felicidad extrema el agradecimiento
siempre y por otro lado también pensar
cada vez me impresiona más como la vida
es una rueda
este no hay cosas que me pasan ahora que
de trabajo que hace 30 años las hice con
alguien que empecé que hice un trabajo y
pasan 30 años y me llaman y me dicen te
te acordás digo ayudarme porque tampoco
me acuerdo tanto digo de dónde y me
empiezan a contar y digo qué prodigio no
que qué bárbaro como lo que uno va esté
haciendo siempre tiene un efecto en los
demás o sea no es que si soy una
malhumorada si contesto mal si soy
quejosa estamos rodeados de quejosos yo
inventé una cuando tengo en el grupo
alguien que yo se lo digo mira la queja
aleja cuando vos te quejas mucho la
gente raja se va no quiere estar con vos
entonces en vez de quejarte todo el
tiempo pensar la solución de todo esto y
tenerlo presente sé consciente como algo
también que me encontré un libro
hace poco en una librería en madrid que
me encantó que era el año del si digo
que es esto y entonces lo investigue y
es una mujer que es una mujer que
después lo book lean y van a ver que no
lo compré porque típico que dije vuelvo
después a la librería y no pase nunca
más por ahí pues este pero me quedé con
ese año del cylog uvi es una mujer que
es muy exitosa que escribe series en
eeuu que le iba fantástico todavía ni un
día la hermana le dijo vos te diste
cuenta que todo en tu vida es no yo te
llamo para comer y es no vamos a acertar
cosas no existe no con uno no sé si
puedo no bueno vamos a ver
está bueno dijo por qué no no yo te voy
a hacer una propuesta
puedo proponerte un año del sí y se lo
propuso y lo hizo y ese sí significó
para ella un cambio fenomenal pero no
sólo para ella sino para todo lo de
alrededor también entonces me parece que
estoy hablando de una
de actitudes y de formas de encarar
también todo con alegría agradecimiento
no poniéndonos todo el tiempo porque el
no que es el no es el miedo que tenemos
el miedo al rechazo el miedo a no servir
este así que yo les propongo empiecen yo
empecé con un mes de sí porque tampoco
un año me parecía dicho por ahí me
comprometo a mucho pero bueno con un mes
de si es bárbaro realmente piensen en
todas las situaciones de la vida donde
aparece esta posibilidad del sí también
y vuelvo e insisto con el tema para mí
fue muy importante la imagen de mi madre
mi madre era maestra trabajaba la mañana
a la tarde y después daba clases en una
escuela nocturna de adultos
y para mí ustedes recuerdan que las
maestras el auto de las maestras era el
citroën
que era típico que era como el auto que
salió en su momento que se les acaban
las puertas se baldeaban un auto
increíble bueno yo recuerdo nosotros
somos tres hermanas cuando mi mamá nos
llevó porque nos dijo voy a elegir el
color del auto que me voy a comprar
para mí mi mamá en ese momento que mujer
maravilla era todo no podía querer que
ella estaba decidiendo estando a mi papá
también que podía
pero son digo las cosas que uno tiene
que hacer también cuando tiene hijos
porque los hijos no hacen lo que uno les
dice sino lo que uno hace y para cerrar
les quiero contar que cuando yo le
quiero dar una bendición a algo a
alguien le digo siempre que encuentres
lo que te gusta
igual la vocación o lo que te gusta
simplemente y puedas hacerlo muchísimas
gracias y lo mejor para todos gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]